sony is going big with the ps5 launch
not only releasing a new console and
controller
but also a wave of accessories in
addition to a camera
charging dock and media remote sony is
putting out a new gaming headset
alongside its next-gen console sony
claims that the pulse takes full
advantage of its tempest 3d audio tech
but the company has also noted that any
headset connected to the console
will be able to make use of it as well
where this leaves us with the pulse
is whether it can outperform third-party
options in the same price range
for 100 you get the pulse headset a usb
wireless adapter
a usbc charging cable and a 3.5
millimeter audio cable for a wired
connection
you're still able to voice chat and use
the ps5 3d audio when plugging headsets
into your controller so if you run out
of battery when using the pulse
wirelessly you can easily plug it into
your dual sense to continue using it
sony claims a battery life of about 12
hours which just about checks out in our
tests
now the audio experience is excellent
for a headset in this price range
i played through the majority of astros
playroom and spider-man miles morales
while using it
and came away impressed by the
experience it provides
whether i was listening to spider-man's
hip-hop soundtrack while miles morales
walked down the street
or hearing the wind blow through me as
spider-man dived between new york
skyscrapers
the audio was always well defined
providing a vibrant experience that
helped make the ps5's worlds feel alive
the console's 3d audio tech also pairs
nicely with the pulse
offering a slight boost to the sounds
around you this
is a subtle effect that makes sounds
like cars whizzing past you more
pronounced
giving you a better idea of which
direction each one is coming from
this isn't exactly game changing but it
is a nice bonus to have
regarding the headset's aesthetics the
meeting of the pulse's white headband
with its black earpieces
gives it an attractive look emulating
the same contrast as the ps5
however where the black is glossy on the
ps5
it's nothing but matte plastic on the
pulse this also applies to its onboard
controls which
consist of nothing but similar feeling
plastic buttons and switches
these are all located on the left ear
and even though i've worn the headset
for multiple charges
i still have issues feeling out which
button is which
however the volume buttons do have a
little tactile dot that makes them
easier to find the pulse's inner
headband on the other hand
is made of soft rubber it adjusts upward
to meet your head where it rests
and sits gently on top as you wear it
considering the headset's all plastic
outer shell
the headband feels surprisingly nice the
ear cushions however
take some time to break in they start
off quite stiff giving a bad first
impression
though it doesn't take long for them to
settle in and become discreet during
extended sessions
those with bigger ears may want to
consider a different headset however
because even after the cushion softened
up i still found my earlobes hanging out
of them making for a less comfortable
experience than other headsets i've
tested
these physical drawbacks are
disappointing sure
but the audio quality and price tag push
the pulse from being a good headset to
an almost great one
there are better headsets out there and
perhaps many that are more comfortable
but at a hundred dollars
sony has hit a price that is hard to
beat for the vivacious
and rich audio experience that the pulse
[Music]
delivers
[Music]
you